this is our fourth installment and our
final installment for this ramadan
an ayah a deeper understanding
here we are the fourth week of ramadan
has passed
we're in the finishing stretch now
this is a time for us to really buckle
down and really really work hard
if what has passed you have not
if you haven't been able to express
what's in your heart as much as you
wanted to
at the beginning of ramadan it's still
not over
it's not over until the adhan of maghrib
of the final day
and the first night of show leila
very possibly could be coming up very
soon insha'allah
and so we are to work as hard as we
can
to try to capitalize on this time
of the year because there were many
people with
us last year that aren't with us this
year
and one day your number is going to be
called your card is going to be pulled
and it will be your final ramadan one
day will be your final day
and so we have to make the best of every
single day
anytime we fall we stumble we fall down
we get up we dust ourselves off and we
keep on marching
marching on our way to allah
this afternoon or this evening i would
to speak about
the 255th verse
of surat al-baqarah this cha this verse
of the quran
is called by the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
the most virtuous
greatest verse of all of the verses of
the quran
and the reason for that is that this
verse
is all about allah subhanahu wa and it
has in it and is comprised of
10 sentences that are only found
singularly
in any verse in any of the quran all
about allah subhanahu wa
it is
the prophet said that
the only thing preventing a person from
entering paradise
who recites ayatollahkursi after every
obligatory prayer is death
so after every obligatory prayer a
person is to recite
ayatul kursi likewise before a person
goes to sleep at night
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
encouraged that a person recite ayatul
kursi
and he mentioned that a person who
recites ayatul kursi before he sleeps
allah subhanahu will send a guardian
to guard him until he wakes up until the
morning
so ayatul kurasi is comprised of ten
sentences
we're not going to go through every
single one of them in detail
it's a very long verse but there
are three main sentences
that kind of sum up the three main
concepts of this
verse this greatest verse of the quran
the first one is the first two sentences
and he follows that up and says
and then he describes himself
so allah is actually the main
name of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala it is
the name
after which all other names of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala follow
and are derived from and this is why it
is referred to
as it is the greatest
of the names of allah subhanahu wa it is
the most
exclusive name of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
across all of the
different religions and different idols
and different philosophies of
all of the arab speaking world of
ancient and current allah
refers only to the one creator who has
created the heavens and the earth
subhana
and so allah what does it mean
i mean
but what does it really mean it
translates to
the one who was worshipped out of love
and exaltation
the one who was exclusively worshipped
out of love and exaltation the only one
who has the right to be worshipped now
when we look at the following sentence
what allah describes himself he says
allah
a phrase that every muslim has memorized
the phrase that you have to know
and have to say and have to acknowledge
and have to proclaim in order for your
islam to be valid even
this is the call of the messenger
[Arabic recitation]
actually this is the call of all of the
prophets and the messengers
allah that
he has never sent a messenger except
that his
message revolved around the statement of
[Arabic recitation]
and the prophet salallahu
that if the seven heavens and the seven
earths were placed in one side of a
scale
[Arabic recitation]
would outweigh them all what does that
mean that means that
is more significant than all of the
creation
why what does
it sounds a pretty fundamental
question a pretty elementary question
some people might even think you know
we're all muslim here why would you even
ask such a question
and you would be amazed and you would be
surprised
at how many muslims if asked directly
what does
they will not be able to give you a very
direct answer
you would be amazed and as imam ahmed
even
mention
him he said
what a terrible people whom abu jahel
knows more about the meaning of
allah than they do even though they
claim they're muslim
we don't want to be of those people and
what is he speaking about
ignorance of the most elemental most
fundamental principles of islam
and that is what is the meaning of
if you ask most people what does
mean many people give you answers such
as there is no god but god there is no
creator but one creator
allah is the only creator and these all
kind of dance around the premise
it is not the meaning of allah
the idolaters those who worshipped other
than allah the most bitter enemies
of the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
they all agreed that there is no creator
but allah subhanahu wa
very few in history actually
have any qualms with that concept that
there is only one creator
rather means that none
is rightfully worshipped but that one
creator subhana
so what does none
is rightfully worship but allah none
is rightfully worshipped but the one and
only creator
and maintainer of the heavens and the
earth subhanna
this is the most prominent of his
descriptions
subhanahu ta'ala that he is allah
none is rightfully worshipped but he
and that is why the narration states
that if the seven heavens if the
creation were in one side of a scale
[Arabic recitation]
outweigh the creation why because
we have all been created for the purpose
of
to worship allah alone without any
partners
we draw our worth
the more you embody
the more value you have with allah
subhanahu wa
even the prophets and messengers
the less you embody
the less status and value you have with
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
therefore all of the creation is
worthless
without la illah we draw our
worth and our value with allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and our status
even the prophets and messengers allah
subhanahu
he says that which translates to in
surat
and we have articulated to you through
revelation
o muhammad you and those prophets that
have preceded you
that if you were to associate anyone in
your worship
of allah along with him all of your
deeds would be nullified
and voided and you would be of the
losers
and so we draw our value
from allah from our worship of allah how
much we embody
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then describes
himself with his greatest name and he
says
the
that allah has a name that if he is
called upon
using this name he will surely respond
and the scholars of islam differ on what
that name is
however there is a narration that points
out that this name is contained in three
chapters of the quran
and the only thing that these three
chapters have in common
of the names of allah is
these two names put together infused
in one chapter are only found in these
three chapters of the quran
the 255th verse of surat al-baqarah
the second verse of surat al-imran and
also a verse in surah
[Silence]
the one who is established and he
establishes everything else subhana
huatada
so he affirms for himself perfection in
himself
and he affirms for himself perfection in
his actions
towards his creation
this is what the scholars mention with
regards to this
this name that allah is perfect in his
names and attributes
and he is as well perfect in his actions
subhana everything that he does
everything he creates everything that he
allows
every action of allah
revolves around this name of allah
al-qaeda
the one who maintains himself the one
who maintains
everything that is in creation
everything that is in existence
another part of this chapter of this
verse
rather that we'd to discuss is the
statement of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
yes
he says rhetorically who is this who
will intercede
on anyone's behalf with allah except
by his permission subhana
intercession is the main root cause
of most polytheism most
idolatry most worship of other than
allah
is actually worship in order to attain
intercession those who worship the
let us and
even even in hinduism there are
more than 20 million documented gods
in this if you want to call it a
religion
right and most of it revolves around the
worship of
saints modern catholicism is all worship
of saints
saint peter and saint joseph and saint
this and saying that
we worship them and then we worship
and the they worship mary and they
worship other than allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala why
in order that they will intercede on
their behalf with allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
but allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
this will not occur
the only intercession that is affirmed
is by
the will of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and it will only be acceptable
for those who are worshipped allah alone
without any partners
if a person worships other than allah he
is automatically
exempt from being interceded on his
behalf
another part of this verse is
where the verse gets its name from
and it's because this is the only place
in the quran where the
corsi of allah is mentioned
that his course has
encompassed all of the heavens and the
earth
what does that mean what is the courtesy
well ibn abbas
he says
he says is the place
and the footstool of the
feet of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ad now
when we describe allah when he describes
himself in the quran
when he describes himself as having a
face
or having hands or having as in this
narration
feet or he is described as having
eyes or he is described subhana
with these descriptions it's important
that you understand something
and that is that we affirm the
description
allah has affirmed it for himself i'm
not going to say
allah has no hands he affirmed it in the
quran
but i say his hands are befitting
to his majesty subhanahu wa the only
thing i am
sure of is that they are completely
unlike
the hands or the descriptions of
anything
that i may conjure up or any of the
creation
clearly says nothing is unto him
and he is the all-hearing he is the
all-hearing all-seeing subhanahu without
this footstool of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
in the correct opinion is placed in
front of the throne of allah
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was narrated by
with an authentic chain of narration to
have said
fifa he said
the seven heavens and the seven earths
are a ring in a vast desert
that's what they are in comparison
to the footstool the courtesy of allah
subhanahu wa
he said and likewise
to the throne of allah is that ring
is to that desert
this is something that is absolutely
unfathomable
something that is totally beyond
what we can imagine the size
of the creation of allah
is the kursi this is the place of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
this is the footstool of allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
let alone the throne of allah
which is carried by eight angels
as allah mentions in the quran
and that he subhanahu in all of his
majesty and glory will arrive on the day
of resurrection
the earth will be illuminated by his
light
to judge and this is the one who we are
going to stand in front of
naked barefoot without
any wealth without any status the only
thing for us
is our relationship with allah
this is the one we are going to stand in
front of in such a vulnerable position
and we are going to be judged by him
subhanahu wa
this is something that is frightening
say the least this is something that is
frightening but it should frighten you
not in a way that
that takes the wind out of your sails
it should frighten you in a way that
motivates you
that is healthy fright and that is what
the quran instills in us
it doesn't instill in us hopelessness
fright
that is unreasonable it should instill
in us
fright that is reasonable and directed
it propels us
and that is why allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala essentially describes himself to
us
subhanahu with such descriptions
to end i will share one narration
after having understood these things i
want to mention one narration
it's a narration in which the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam says
there is not one of you except that he
will stand in front of allah and allah
will speak to him directly without
any intermediary or any translator
he said
and so when a person is in this position
you i
all of us will be in this position
imagine yourself he says a person in
this position
he is there before the glory and the
majesty of allah
he is thinking back to the pettiness of
the life of this world
he's thinking about the sacrifices he
foolishly made for the life of this
transient world
he will look to his right and he will
only see his deeds
the right represents the good deeds
and he will look to his left which
represents the bad deeds
and he will only see what he has put
forth for himself
so you look to what you've done of good
to appease this magnificent
being allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and you
will see such
petty little things that you've done of
good
that you've been able to muster up
you'll belittle it
and you'll look to your left and you'll
see the times when you ignored allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and you disobeyed
him
and you will see these sins as being
very grave
after comparing the two a person will
look ahead
and the only thing he will be able to
see in his mind's
eye is the fire licking at his
face
he says so protect yourselves from the
fire even if you can only muster up half
a date
in charity
and whoever can't even muster that much
at least a good word that is spoken
do something to protect yourself build
some kind of relationship with allah
if you are on the path and you stumble
and you fall
down you may have an excuse but if you
are not on the path and you haven't
tried at all you have
no excuse with allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
there is no excuse to not try and we may
fail
trying but we will never fail to try
we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
benefit us all from what we have heard
to enlighten us with the quran to grant
us
success during this month and make us of
those who are emancipated from the fire
thank you for watching
so